>> Tucker: WELL THE CORONAVIRUS
LOCKDOWNS HURT THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE BEEN GREAT FOR
COMPANIES THAT DON’T LIKE THE
COUNTRY.
LIKE AMAZON.
THEY PROFITED MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
SMALL BUSINESSES AND RESTAURANTS
ESPECIALLY HAVE BEEN DESTROYED.
RESEARCH BY THE WEBSITE YELP
HALF OF THE RESTAURANTS SHUT
DOWN FOR THE CORONAVIRUS CLOSED
BY GOOD BY JULY.
ONE RESTAURANT THAT REFUSED TO
CLOSE WAS IN MAINE.
THE OWNER CAME ON THIS SHOW IN
APRIL TO ANNOUNCE HE WILL WOULD
REMAIN OPEN IN DEFIANCE OF THE
ONE OF THE WORST GOVERNORS IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> WE ENCOURAGE ALL BUSINESSES
IN MAINE TO OPEN UP.
GET THIS SUMMER TOURIST GOING OR
WE WILL LOSE A THIRD OF
RESTAURANTS AND HOTEL AND OTHER
BUSINESSES.
IT’S TIME TO GO BACK TO WORK.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS IN APRIL.
RICK SAFFINGVAGE DEFIED THE GOVE
WHO IS VICIOUS.
SHE SET OUT TO DESTROY HIS LIFE.
FINALLY JANET MILLS GOT HIS
RESTAURANT SHUT DOWN THIS WEEK.
RICK SAVAGE JOINS US TONIGHT
WITH AN UPDATE.
YOU KNEW YOU WERE TAKING A RINK
SPEAKING AGAINST YOUR GOVERNOR.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE IN
A FREE COUNTRY.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> 100%.
TUCKER, SINCE I CAME ON YOUR
SHOW.
WE OPENED UP AND SHE HAD THE
STATE TROOPERS IN HER OFFICE AT
9 O’CLOCK TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SHUT US DOWN.
WE OPENED UP AT 11.
THEY SHOWED UP AFTER 4.
HEALTH INSPECTORS.
THEY SHOOK OUR HANDS AND WALKED
THEM DOWN TO THE OFFICE.
6 OF US IN A 6 BY 12 OFFICE.
THE HEALTH INSPECTOR TOOK OUR
HEALTH LICENSE WHICH MEANS WE
CAN’T SERVE BOOZE.
WE SIGNED THE PAPERWORK.
WE WERE GOOD WITH THEM.
THEY LEFT.
THE NEXT DAY WE GOT ANOTHER ONE.
WE ARE UP TO LIKE 30 INSPECTIONS
SINCE I WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
THEY OPENED UP A COURT FOR US.
THE COURTS WERE SHUT DOWN.
SHE OPENED UP THE COURTS FOR US.
THESE ARE THE COURT PAPERS SINCE
MAY 1st.
WE HAVE BEEN CLEAN AND OPEN AND
DONE 85,000 PEOPLE.
NO CASES.
SAME PEOPLE IN THERE EVERY DAY.
SAME STAFF AND SAME PEOPLE AT
THE BAR.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
AT ALL THAT YOUR RESTAURANT HAS
BEEN A SOURCE OF CORONAVIRUS
INFECTIONS?
ANY REASON FOR DOING THIS TO
YOU?
>> NOT AT ALL.
NONE.
THEY HAVE BEEN FINING ME $600 A
DAY FOR MONTHS TO STAY OPEN.
THE HEALTH INSPECTORS IN MY
OFFICE DID NOT HAVE MASKS ON AND
DIDN’T DO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THE HEALTH INSPECT OROR CAME IN
SEVERAL TIMES WITH NO PROTECTION
GEAR.
WE ARE THE MOST INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANT IN THE STATE OF
MAINE.
THE ONLY RESTAURANT IN THE STATE
OF MAINE THAT HAS BEEN IN COURT.
WE ARE THE ONLY RESTAURANT IN
THE STATE OF MAINE THEY SHUT
DOWN.
WE ARE THE ONLY 2 PEOPLE MY
BROTHER AND MYSELF THAT HAVE
A MASK MANDATE THAT ORDERS ME TO
WEAR A MASK 100% OF A TIME IN MY
RESTAURANT EVEN IF I AM EATING
OR DRINKING.
I MADE A DEAL I WOULD STAY OUT
OF MY OWN RESTAURANT TO KEEP
THIS OPEN FOR MY STAFF.
NO THEY STRUCK IT DOWN.
IMPOSED A $5,000 FINE ON US
STARTING TODAY.
SHE WAS CHUCKLING LIKE A KID IN
A CANDY STORE.
I HAVE 65 FAMILIES THAT WORK
THERE.
WE ARE COME INTO HOLIDAYS.
WE WILL TAKE CARE OF OUR STAFF
FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
MY BROTHER AND MYSELF DON’T WORK
IN THAT RESTAURANT.
WE HAVE 6 OTHER COMPANIES.
THEY ARE SINGLING ME OUT BECAUSE
I CALLED HER OUT.
WE HAD A COMMISSIONER OF ALCOHOL
AT A MEETING 2 WEEKS AGO, A ZOOM
MEETING.
HE SAID IN THE ZOOM MEETING, HE
APOLOGIZED FOR BEING BEHIND AND
WORKING ON A 39 COUNTS AGAINST
A BREWING CRUMP.
>> Tucker: THE MEDIA IN YOUR
STATE IS CORRUPT AND TOOK THE
SIDE OF YOUR GOVERNOR WHO IS
INCOMPETENT.
RICK SAVAGE, I HOPE YOU WILL
COME BACK AND TELL US HOW THE
STORY ENDS.
>> WE HAVE A GO FUND ME.
WE RAISED $100,000 AND WE GAVE
IS BACK TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
USED THE REST FOR LAWYERS.
IT’S ABOUT THE FREEDOM IN THE
PEOPLE IN MAINE.
WE ARE IN A REALLY BAD SPOT.
WE WILL LOSE A LOT MORE